thanks to brilliant org for sponsoring
this video fantasy is filled with
incredible flying creatures from the
Dragons of Game of Thrones to the
hippogriffs of Harry Potter that unlike
anything we see in the natural world in
both form and size thank God
but being both a serious geek and a
scientist I can't help but wonder could
these creatures really exist does the
physics add up that they could fly to
answer this question in this video I'm
going to apply real physics and biology
to fantasy creatures by looking at
extant and extinct species of bats and
birds and by talking to experts and how
those creatures fly but to begin with we
need to know a bit more about flying
fantasy creatures and while I know a few
things about fantasy I happen to know
some people who are much more qualified
to talk about it my name is Mark Humes
I call myself a professional dungeon
master which sounds very very full of
myself
I run a Dungeons & Dragons campaign
called high rollers we have our own
twitch channel but we're also partnered
with the yogscast that we stream on
every Sunday at 5 p.m. GMT and we've
been doing it for two years now my name
is Mark turbine or Terps from the
yogscast i'm the CEO here the we're met
the guys and got my job and all the fan
is I've been playing World of Warcraft
now for about 15 years is where in
essence the yogscast was formed and it's
where i spend the vast majority of my
time and i've been playing and talking
about world warcraft probably in time
most of my life so it's fair to say then
that these guys know their stuff i ask
them to go through what kind of flying
creatures exist in fantasy and got a
comprehensive list yeah there's a lot of
them Griffins dragons the Horde had
Winans manticores chimeras bone Drake's
Pegasus hippogriffs beholders horses can
can fly in Warcraft sometimes they give
them wings and then like Pegasus
sometimes they just have Sparky who's
there's a creature called a dark mantle
which is like an umbrella
that's like evil and is like an octopus
umbrella that like falls down from the
ceiling it's very very weird some of the
old Dean these stuff is very very
strange there's a piloted sky golem
which is basically like a Iron Man suit
you just kind of
put it on and off you go so you have
creatures that fly via magic like the
beholder who's a big bag of floating
eyes winged creatures all battling
creatures and I think like winged
creatures you're talking about things
like Griffins pegasi and then the bat
wings is for creatures like chimeras
manticores dragons devils that kind of
stuff and I think yeah they fall into
those two categories so necessarily
disregarding those creatures which fly
exclusively through magic we're left
with mythical creatures which fly in a
way comparable to real animals to begin
with let's focus on those creatures with
bird wings but it turns out there's
something of a problem with applying
physics to bird flight we don't really
know how it works
so we've got good idea of how birds and
insects and planes fly how they generate
lift but it's it's a very complex
interaction of forces and yeah we still
don't have it all quite nailed down
that's dr. Alex Evans who just completed
his PhD in bird flight my PhD is on the
biomechanics and energetics of bird
flights I work with birds mostly small
parrots we have a wind tunnel at the
University so we're able to fly them at
a variety of speeds and whilst they're
flying we can measure various mechanical
and metabolic aspects of their flight
and we can also film the birds flying
and generate kinematic analysis and 3d
model reconstructions of what the wings
are doing in flights so birds don't all
just fly in one uniform way there's a
variety of different styles of flights
depending on how big the bird is bigger
birds tend to have a slower wing beats
and they generally make use of energy
efficient methods of flying such as
soaring and they're able to fly sustain
flight for a very long time on with
little energy whereas other birds much
smaller birds tend to use flapping fly
em up a lot more but even they don't
just flap all the time they might have a
bounding flight where they're flapping
for a certain amount of time and then
they're gliding for a certain amount of
time and so it varies a lot depending on
how fast the birds going how big they
are
and generally what they use in their
flight for whether it's hunting or
escaping so to apply physics to our
flying mythical creatures we have to be
more specific in how we expect them to
fly looking
the creatures in World of Warcraft and
D&D most of the wings seem to be similar
to those of medium to large Raptors like
eagles and hawks which fire using a
soaring or intermittent flapping gates
depending on what they're doing given
this information we can now ask a bunch
of questions perhaps the most basic of
which is based on the species we know
fly in this way are the wings depicted
on fantasy creatures actually large
enough to carry them aloft to try and
answer that question I use this paper
published in 1989 by Mendelssohn EDL
which measured various characteristics
of a large number of African Raptors
using data from this paper if you plot
the mass of these species against their
respective wing spans you get this graph
as the mass of the bird increases so too
does its wingspan as we'd expect if you
could fit a line to this data you could
extrapolate and ask for a very heavy
mythical creature like a Griffon how big
would its wings need to be however this
data isn't linear you can't fit a simple
straight line to it so my idea of a
simple extrapolation to much heavier
animals didn't work fortunately dr.
Evans had a much better suggestion
because an alternative way of measuring
wings to wingspan is wing area and
wrapped up in the wing area is
information about how a bird flies in
just two numbers firstly if you divide
the wing area of a bird by its body mass
you get a quantity known as wing loading
this is effectively the amount of weight
that each square centimeter of the wing
has to support in flight that's the
first number the second number is the
aspect ratio of the wing that is how
long the wing is versus how wide it is
so an albatross has very long wings with
a relatively low area and so has a high
aspect ratio while a puffin on the other
hand has adorable short wings but
they're wide so has a low aspect ratio
if you scatter plot these two quantities
that wing loading and the aspect ratio
for a variety of bird species then you
get a really interesting graph birds
which soar and don't really flap their
wings like Swift's and albatrosses are
up here at the top
compare that to birds which can only
just about fly like puffins which are
way over here on the right popular
in this graph with lots of species
you'll see that the African birds of
prey in the paper are all clustered
around one area that means two things
firstly that their wings all share
roughly the same wing loading if you
plot the wing area of these species
against their mass it's a lovely
straight line that means that we can
extrapolate it neatly to a giant
mythical animal and get a rough
prediction of how much wing area it
would need to fly like an eagle secondly
the birds all share approximately the
same wing aspect ratio and because of
this we can convert the predicted wing
area to a predicted wingspan so our wing
area graph allows us to predict a wing
area for any mass of animal that we want
and we can then convert that wing area
to a wing span by assuming an aspect
ratio informed by the data in the paper
what we find is that for an animal
flying like a raptor and weighing a ton
the weight of a large horse and so what
I approximated the way every creature
like a Griffon would be its wingspan
would need to be just under 20 meters
for context that's nearly double the
wingspan of the classic Cessna 172 light
aircraft for a giant creature like a
Griffon to fly it would need to have
huge wings much bigger than its depicted
to have in for example lot of warcraft'
what's cool about this calculation
though is that you can calculate a
wingspan for a flying creature flying
like a raptor with any mass including
the mass of a human you would have a
wingspan just shy of 6 meters if you
were so three meters either way yeah
which incidentally is the wingspan of
one of the very largest birds in the
fossil record the Condor like argent
Arvest which must have been absolutely
terrifying however there is a huge
problem with this analysis it's not just
because in adding wings to a body you're
increasing the mass of the body and so
increasing the size of the wings needed
and so increasing the mass of the body
and so on it's to do with how the wings
would be powered and connected so the
problem with most mythical creatures
such as dragons and other large flag
beasts they also tend to have four limbs
as well as wings is the musculature just
as doesn't quite make sense so for birds
to fly
they rely a lot on the pectoralis
muscles so in the birds I work with
small parrots they make up 75% of that
total muscle mass and about 15% of their
total body mass and so if you have say a
Hippogriff it's got four legs and it's
pecks muscles like being used they're
already attached to some limbs so where
these muscles that powering the giant
wings on their back come from I I don't
know how they would attach is beyond me
so for a creature depicted to have both
wings and front legs like hippogriffs or
Griffin's musculature just doesn't make
any sense with front legs there are no
muscles left to power the wings so the
feather creatures we've seen have wings
which are too small and have no muscles
to power them
so unfortunately based on known biology
they couldn't exist dragons and Dragon
like creatures however are a very
different story
Humes was pessimistic about whether
anything like them could really exist
that stuff like dragons like I mean you
look at this and like the bulk of it I
don't think that unless I don't know
maybe the strength its strength would be
enough to make it fly I don't know
struggle with that one but I would say
generally no I don't think so but just
wait let's apply some science the
closest parallel to dragon wings in
biology are those of mega bats you might
think of bats as been small
insectivorous animals probably not much
bigger than your hand but they get
really big these are Livingston's fruit
bats some of the largest bats in the
world kept in captivity at Durrell a
conservation charity on the island of
Jersey
Livingston's are about one point four
meter wingspan with about 7 to 800 grams
body mass so that puts them up there
pretty high the largest is it's got my
Latin pronunciation is terrible but it's
the golden crown flying fox from the
Philippines and it can get up to you
think it's about 1.8 meter wingspan and
then they say a 1.6 kilo bat so that's a
pretty hefty bat that's
Bell a keeper of mammals at Durrell who
works with the bats I asked him how bat
flight was different to bird flies it
comes down to announcer mesa bats
effectively were flying with their hands
carp terror does come from the I think
the really bad break down his Greek
forehand wing so you've got basically
the bones of our hand but imagine what
makes up that palm or pushed up under
the thumb so that big hook they've got a
lovely big thumb the second and third
digit so your index and your middle
finger they create what would be like
the leading edge of a wing so if you're
thinking of like the Batman symbol that
will be the bit that goes all the way
out right to the edge and the two points
that kind of come down and create those
lovely kind of big arcs that will be
their fourth and fifth digits and each
of those has got a nice big really
clever piece of skin attached between it
really cool that she's covered in micro
hairs cuz they're mammals just like us
they have got loads of hairs all over
their bodies some sizes start to show
they can detect ever so slightly changes
in like barometric pressure airspeed
winds being as they're flying and that
creates really like micro alterations in
the surface of the wing so when you look
at a bats wing you've got a perfect
complete surface area there is no gaps
in it now that differs from birds in the
sense that feathers obviously they're
growing out of the bones at the ends the
bird's wing and they're controllable in
a sense they can shift and change a
little bit but they're not as dexterous
as a bats wing so whereas birds can
actually get quite a lot of nice
lightweight lift they can be while a
certain species can be incredibly agile
bats I've got a little bit of an edge in
terms of agility because their fingers
can control every single part of the
wing membrane they can collapse they can
crunch and they can allow that kind of
yeah instant turn and movement what I
wanted to do for the bats was the same
calculation we did earlier for birds
extrapolating from current species to
some huge mythical animal but edie
mentioned something really interesting
about bat flight specifically that makes
such extrapolation impossible there's a
limit to how much muscle and kind of
like weight of muscle ratio and also
flapping motions that a bat can create
when she lifts its way off the ground
that exponentially they wouldn't be able
to kind of have more muscle and black
harder so there is like a cap on how
much a back way and they estimate about
one point six at the minute will
probably be the heaviest and as far as
the fossil record goes as well that's
probably the biggest we've ever seen
I've got a paper I can send you to have
a quick flick through
was this paper from norburg and norburg
which is a fascinating if dense read
basically the authors looked on how as
bats get larger and larger the wingbeat
frequency required to take flight
decreases so bigger bats don't have to
flap their wings as quickly as small
bats to take off but at the same time
the fastest that a bat can beat its
wings also decreases as the bat gets
bigger their wings just get too big to
flap quickly and interestingly the
maximum wingbeat frequency possible
decreases faster with size than the
minimum wingbeat frequency required and
for flight so that means there's a
theoretical limit on how big a creature
can be with bat wings and still be able
to fly a limit that we've probably
already hit in the philippine golden
crown flying fox yes by the way to fend
off people in the comments massless I'm
very smart a similar analysis was also
done for birds by penny cubic and found
a maximum mass of 16 kilograms for
cruising bucking flight but then there
are other factors such as alternative
gates which allow for even bigger birds
that reach out impoverished oh my god I
forgot how big it was fat suffer from
this limit quicker than birds because of
love portion their body mass being
flight muscles and from their wings be
made of skin rather than feathers I hope
you're happy this kind of kills the
discussion of dragons dead but if we
assume that mythical creatures have some
different muscle composition or wings
with slightly different properties then
maybe we could paper over this so I
asked Edie which mythical creatures he
thought could exist based on some
modified bat biology Wyman's could work
they've got like the same kind of body
structure in a way maybe a quite large
tail I think mass size that when they
start to get as big as dragons are
depicted I just yeah don't know how that
could ever lift off a smaller Dragons
maybe if you had like baby dragons or
yeah like all the dragons from Game of
Thrones before they got too big yeah I
could I could see them working but many
they get to like full size and you can
start writing them out I think physics
might be on the other side and that's
where magic comes into it so completely
fine relying heavily on this excuse of
magic then humans and I decided to do a
bit of backyard maths on the ancient red
dragon model he had it doesn't have bird
wings but we thought it might be fun to
see what gate it might have measuring
its wings to the best of our abilities
and trawling various D&D resources for
its weight we
to mated the dragon's wing loading an
aspect ratio and comparing them to the
bird species from before it places on
the graph here very similar to condors
so not flying like a mega bat at all
instead it would soar and probably need
help in taking off like jumping off a
cliff
so apparently about the same as a condor
there you go look at that if it like if
we ignore all the other physical problem
the way I've always done it is like for
them to take off is like a lot of work
like they have to really kind of get
going with and once they're up they can
kind of just open their wings and yeah
based on his knowledge and actually
agreed with this kind of flight pattern
for dragons and wyverns I guess if a
dragon lived on the top of the mountain
and was prepared to throw itself well
can get enough lift to be able to take
off and fly yeah it could happen me
whatever we want to see unfortunately
the way things are going the
Livingston's fruit bat might soon be
just as mythical as the dragons and
Griffin's we've been talking about in
this video it's critically endangered ed
works on stopping the species from going
extinct
yeah it's priority project for us on the
mammal Department at the minute their
numbers are about 1260 across about 20
to 30 roosts on the two islands so
they're incredibly low and the biggest
threat at this minute in time would be a
one-off cyclone look it just pretty much
decimate the entire population so having
them here in captivity is still a
critical safety net for the population
but it also facilitates a massive amount
of research we've got really good
partners out in the chemours Club bihari
they're an organization we helped
establish back in 2013 but they're a
complete separate NGO
they are doing amazing community
agroforestry and agricultural work
Durrell and their partners in the field
do truly fantastic work saving species
from extinction and working with local
populations I'll leave a link in the
description so you can learn more about
their work with loads of different
animals and if you have any money going
spare every single penny donated makes a
real difference to species like the
Livingston's
so after all this analysis which
mythical beasts could really fly the
major problem with a lot of the species
shown in fantasy is the musculature
petra muscles are needed to power wings
so any species shown to have both front
legs and wings doesn't really make any
sense from a typical flying pantheon
pretty much just leaves wyverns although
two other possible species which turps
and mark didn't mention are cockatrices
and harpies while real-life biology
indicates that harpies women with wings
for arms could exist they would need a
much bigger wingspan than is normally
depicted dragon wing creatures like
cockatrices and wyverns wouldn't be able
to flap their wings fast enough to take
flight but if we allow for a little bit
of magic or even just alternative
biology these creatures might fly in a
similar way to condors more about
soaring than flapping and with an
assistant takeoff but if you play hard
your mount might just be possible in the
real world at the end of the day though
does it matter that the creatures in
World of Warcraft and Dungeons & Dragons
are unphysical no absolutely not I'm not
looking for the real world in D&D
sometimes the brilliance of fantasy is
that it's not real and that it's
completely different and it's
imaginative and you can go somewhere the
beauty of Dungeons & Dragons and I tend
to favor campaigns that we call high
magic settings you can't get that stuff
in the real world like we have enough of
the real world in the rest of our media
whereas in fantasy almost anything goes
and I love that firstly I want my
fantasy to remain crazy you know that's
the point of it that's i-i've got other
you know normal stuff it's called the
real world and I'm trying to spend it a
little time in it as possible thank you
very much as a scientist I love to watch
fantasy that's grounded itself in
reality and tries to make its magic feel
real but sometimes you don't want that
sometimes you want the fantastical and
based on the number of stories
throughout history and around the world
perhaps there's something in all of us
that just wants an impossible gigantic
flying lizard that breathes fire to be
real just not near me please in this
video I used some basic statistical
techniques and analyzed scientific
literature to apply real science to
fantasy I have some expertise in these
fields what with the master's degree and
the PhD but you don't have to spend
eight years university to learn how to
use these skills and do this kind of
analysis if you found this video
interesting then you might want to take
a look at brilliant org brilliant is an
educational website appropriate for
students from age
twelve to age 200 who would like to
learn by getting their hands dirty and
solving problems what I did in this
video is an example of how you learn on
britain tog you learn a new idea of fact
and apply your knowledge to some new
situation and just like in this video if
you get that wrong it's absolutely fine
by making mistakes you allow yourself to
improve it highlights things that you
might have missed conceived or missed
remembered and allows you to improve
your understanding I can't guarantee
that your understanding will involve
dragons however the fastest way to learn
a new skill is to simply try using it
and learn from your mistakes in an
intelligent way you can use parts of
brilliance for free so if there's really
no excuse to not check it out and you
can also get a premium account for
either yourself or as a gift for a
student you know which gives access to
their fantastic guided courses if you're
interested in getting a premium account
then use the link in the description but
into org slash Simon Clarke and the
first 200 people to do so will get 20%
off thank you so much for watching this
video it has been a real labor of love
over the past couple of months this
channel has undergone something of a
hiatus for a while and there is a vlog
coming out very soon explaining why that
is no small part of it is this video
which is probably most ambitious video
project I've ever done so I do have to
say a massive thank you to everyone who
made it possible
notably dr. Evans Alex thank you so much
for being interviewed if you are
interested in biology definitely check
out his Twitter there'll be a link in
the description because he's always
tweeting about some really interesting
stuff and also thank you to Edie a belt
from Durrell for agreeing to talk to me
I already talked about Daryl's work in
the video if you are interested in
conservation and you think it's
worthwhile stopping species going
extinct then check out another link in
the description to Daryl's work and
consider making a donation they are one
of the most important charities in the
world I also have to say huge thank you
to Terps and humans from the ox cast it
was so much fun coming and filming in
the studios with you guys and thank you
for sharing your expertise I learned an
awful lot I hope that it came across in
the video but these guys really do know
their stuff and yeah it was great fun I
learned a lot on the trip and I hope
that you guys have enjoyed watching the
video links to their social zand to the
twitch for high rollers which i highly
highly recommend them a fan are down
there in the description okay now this
is turning into an Oscar acceptance
speech
so basically thank you to everyone who
made this video possible thank you
you for watching and I will see you in
the next one